planning is underway this morning for a
royal wedding in London I can't wait I'm
not even invited I can't wait the palace
announced this morning that Prince Harry
is engaged to his girlfriend American
actress Megan Markel Charlie d'Agata is
outside Kensington Palace with the
impact the couple could have on the
royal family Charlie good morning good
morning well speculation had reached a
fever pitch over the weekend that Prince
Harry had indeed popped the question all
we were waiting for was the official
announcement well we got that this
morning and this cause for celebration
on both sides of the Atlantic I think
Prince Harry's engagement to Megan Marco
is a game changer for the royal family
before Harry met Megan fairytale royal
weddings used to go something like this
the eligible Prince plucks his ladylove
from obscurity showers who are at
publicity and makes her a princess bride
then came Megan Markel already famous in
her own right as the star of the hit
drama series suits pretty good you've
hit on me she's from the US has an
african-american mother and over two
million followers on social media she is
completely different previous worldwide
we've seen in recent generations like
the Duchess of Cambridge like Prince
Diana this is a woman who's had a career
if she's been married before she's had a
very different background two members of
the royal family 36 year-old Markel was
born and raised in Los Angeles her
parents separated when she was two I
need your help she went into acting and
shot to fame when she landed the role of
Rachel Zane in 2011 so why are you
coming to me Markel has used her
celebrity to campaign for gender
equality and the empowerment of young
women I am proud to be a woman and a
feminist and shares Harry's dedication
to charitable causes a former Army
officer kerrie founded the annual
Invictus games for wounded veterans this
year was the first time the Prince and
the star appeared together at an
official event just before meeting
Markel in 2016 Harry sat down with Norah
O'Donnell at the Invictus games in
Florida do you want to have kids and
for that question to that of course you
know who doesn't you know time you know
time time time will tell and I'm looking
forward to the opportunity pretty busy
at the moment so my focus is on making
sure this week carries on without any
any issues and making sure that we we
Tim UK goes back with as many gold
medals as possible kids can wait famous
last words maybe Harry Met Megan through
mutual friends in London and managed to
keep their relationship secret for six
months but when the news leaked
Britain's tabloids swarmed Harry wasn't
amused the past week has seen a line
crossed he warned claiming Markel had
been subject to a wave of abuse and
harassment and that he was worried about
her safety but Markel herself opened up
in a cover story for Vanity Fair where
two people who were really happy and in
love she described the tabloid frenzy as
noise some things like the media scrum
remain a fact of life
for a royal bride-to-be but Harry's
choice of an independently wealthy
American celebrity divorcee signals that
the times are a-changing even inside
this famously buttoned-up institution
the Brits like to call the firm what it
shows is that the royal family are
finally ready to modernize a bit to
advance a bit and to let Prince Harry
actually follow his heart
rather than world traditional convention
and that's groundbreaking now we haven't
got an exact date for the wedding all
we're told is it'll happen sometime in
the spring remember the kate is
expecting a baby in April all we do know
is that the event is likely to be
something spectacular spectacular
Charlie d'Agata in London thank you well
so happy for the both of them yeah I
just love love and I love with it I do I
love what the woman said there that it's
a game changer for the royal family and
you get the sense that people are really
cheering them on which is nice yeah it's
gonna be great when pop in circumstance
and the difficult times we've been
living in Iran
baby and the wedding yes thank coming
man